♪♪
KRAGLIN
I just saw on the calendar that right now
on Earth it's almost Christmas time.
NEBULA
We don't have time for
trivialities like Christmas.
MANTIS
But Peter's so sad about
Gamora being gone.
♪♪
MANTIS
Maybe if we go to Earth for a really
wonderful Christmas gift...
...it would make him happy.
[Cheering]
MANTIS
Something special he will never forget.
DRAX
What about someone special?
MANTIS
We’re looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon.
DRAX
We're looking for the
legendary Kevin Bacon!
MANTIS
I just said that, Drax!
DRAX
But your voice is small and mousey,
I think maybe he didn't hear you.
[Screams]
DRAX
You're coming with us...
...as a Christmas present.
♪♪
GROOT
I am Groot!